good morning everyone first off I'd like
to thank all of you guys for choosing to
attend my presentation today but before
I get started I wanted to address the
potential confusion around the topic of
my talk today unfortunately this won't
be about the city of Brooklyn New York
or its beautiful bridge hopefully you
guys came here to learn about this
Brooklyn so people ask me all the time
when I place orders for swags such as
t-shirts hats or stickers with our
custom logo on it are you sure you meant
to spell Brooklyn like that with an eye
and not a why and I always have to
reassure them that I did intend to spell
Brooklyn like this so where did we get
the name Brooklyn with an eye well the
definition of a Brooke is a stream and
at LinkedIn we always try to like we
always like to try to find clever ways
to incorporate the word in in our team
names event names project names so if
you put Brooke and in together well that
gives you Brooke in but that sounds an
awful lot like broken and that's not
what we wanted to name our product after
so instead if you combine the word
Brooke and Linkedin well that gives you
Brooke LinkedIn which sounds maybe a
little bit better but still a little bit
awkward so what we did was we simply
dropped the latter half of that word and
that's how we came up with Brooklyn
here's a picture of me wearing a t-shirt
with our custom logo on it my name is
Celia kung and I manage the data
pipelines team which includes Brooklyn
as part of the streams infrastructure or
get LinkedIn so I LinkedIn it's sort of
a tradition that whenever we're
introducing ourselves to an audience or
a group of people for the first time to
share something about us that is not on
our LinkedIn profile so something that's
not on my LinkedIn profile is I have
four pet cats that I adopted and I've
taught one of them to do a high-five so
surprisingly it's not that difficult to
teach a cat to do a high-five it took
probably less than a week and this is
only true if they're highly motivated by
food like I am okay so now let's dive
into the presentation here's a little
bit of an overview of what I'll be
covering today first I'll give a brief
background and motive
a Chinon why we needed to build a
service like Brooklyn and then I'll talk
about some of the scenarios that
Brooklyn was designed to handle
including some of the real use cases for
it within LinkedIn then I'll give an
overview of the Brooklyn architecture
and lastly I'll talk about where
Brooklyn is today and our plans for the
future so when we talk about streams
infrastructure one of the main focuses
is serving Nearline applications
which are those that require a near
real-time response so in the order of
seconds to maybe minutes there are
thousands of such applications that
LinkedIn for example the live search
indices or notifications that you might
get when one of your connections has
changed their job because these Nearline
applications are always processing
they're requiring continuous and low
latency access to data and this data
could be spread out across multiple data
systems database systems for example at
LinkedIn
Weesa store most of our source of truth
data in Oracle and as we grew we built
our own document database called
espresso we then started to store some
data in my sequel and Kafka and LinkedIn
acquired some companies that built their
applications on top of AWS and then
LinkedIn itself got acquired by
Microsoft which called for the need to
stream data in and out of azure
so over the years LinkedIn data became
spread out across many heterogeneous
data systems and to continue to support
all of these Nearline applications that
needed this continuous and low latency
access to all of this data we needed to
build the right framework to support
streaming from these various sources
from a company's perspective we wanted
to allow our application developers to
focus on application logic and data
processing logic and not on the movement
of data so the streams infrastructure
team at LinkedIn was tasked with finding
the right infrastructure to enable this
when we had most of our data in Oracle
and our document store called espresso
we had actually built a change data
capture system called data bus which was
used to capture changes Mesa dated made
to the data
and stream them to Nearline applications
but the problem with this is that it
didn't scale very well because the
solution for streaming data out of
Oracle was pretty specialized and
separate from the solution to stream
data out of espresso despite the fact
that these two were both in the same
product called data bus and at this
point we needed to add support for even
more sources like Kafka and event hubs
and so what we could have done was we
could have written separate streaming
systems as part of data bus to support
this but what we really learned was that
building separate and specialized
solutions to stream data to and from
each different system is it really slows
down our development and is extremely
hard to manage what we really needed was
a centralized managed and extensible
service that could continuously deliver
data in near real-time to our
applications and this led us to the
development of Brooklyn so now that you
know a little bit about the motivation
on why we needed to build Brooklyn what
is Brooklyn Brooklyn is a streaming data
pipeline service that has the ability to
propagate data from many source too many
destination types it is also a
multi-tenant which means that it can run
several thousands of streams
simultaneously and all within a single
cluster each of these data pipelines can
be individually configured and
dynamically provisioned meaning that you
don't need to make a bunch of static
config file changes and deploy a new
cluster every time you just want to spin
up a new data pipeline and perhaps the
biggest reason why we built Brooklyn was
to make it easily extensible to plug in
support for additional sources and
destinations going forward so we really
built Brooklyn with extensibility in
mind this is sort of like a high-level
picture of what this looks like on the
right hand side you have all of these
Nearline applications that are
interested in streaming data from a
variety of sources which you have on the
left hand side and Brooklyn is
responsible for capturing these changes
and shipping these events to any variety
of destinations where are
kitchens can asynchronously consume from
so four sources we mainly focus on two
types which are databases and messaging
systems with the most heavily used
databases at LinkedIn being espresso and
Oracle and the most heavily misused
messaging system being Kafka and at
LinkedIn most of our applications
consume from Kafka as a destination so
now that you have a high level picture
of what Brooklyn looks like I'll talk
about some of the scenarios that
Brooklyn was designed to handle and most
of these fall into two major buckets the
first scenario is what is known as
change data capture which involves
capturing live updates made to databases
and streaming them in the form of a low
latency change stream and to show you
what I mean by change data capture I'll
walk through a very simple example of
how change data capture is used at
LinkedIn so suppose that there is a
LinkedIn member whose name is Moche who
updates her LinkedIn profile to reflect
her recent jobs which she used to work
as a litter box janitor at a company
called scoop and now she is working at a
company called zze catnip dispensary
where she works as a sales clerk as a
social professional network LinkedIn
wants to inform Mochis colleagues of her
new job change so for example this is
the view of Rollo who was one of Mochis
connections and we want to show this
update on Rolo's newsfeed so that he can
easily engage in this update by
commenting or liking this post to
congratulate his friend on her new role
one way to enable this use case is so
mochis profile data is stored in a
database called a member database and a
profile table and one way to enable this
use case is to have the new speed
service constantly query the member
database directly to try to detect
whenever a profile has changed and this
can work at somewhat of a small scale
but suppose that you have another
application called search in DC service
that is also interest
in listening to changes that are made to
member profile data because for example
if a user searches for zze catnip
dispensary on linkedin they want Moche
to show up in the search results of this
new company and no longer in the search
results of her previous company so again
the search industry service could also
constantly query the member database
doing select star queries to try to
figure out what has changed since the
last time that it ran a select star
query but you can imagine that there are
many such applications that are
interested in listening to changes made
to member profile data to power critical
applications in the LinkedIn site such
as notifications or title
standardization so they could all follow
a similar approach but as the size of
your database grows or the number of
applications grows you are at risk of
bringing down the database if you
continue to do this because these select
star queries are extremely expensive so
you don't want a live read or write to a
LinkedIn profile to a LinkedIn members
profile on the live site to be slow or
not work just because there are a bunch
of back-end jobs that are also trying to
listen to the live database so how do we
do this how do we solve this we solve
this by a known pattern called change
data capture where in these applications
don't query the live database directly
but they instead listen to these live
updates by consuming from what is called
as a change stream and Brooklyn is the
force behind capturing the updates made
to the database and streaming them to
the change stream there are several
advantages to doing it this way
first you get good isolation between the
applications and the live and online
resource because they don't compete for
for resources on the live database and
secondly these applications and
databases can scale independently of
each other and applications can be at
different points in the change timeline
so because they are reading from a
change stream and not from the live
database itself each application can
just be at different points in time
this is what the setup of change data
capture looks like with Brooklyn at
LinkedIn so as you can see here Brooklyn
is the one that's responsible for
capturing the live updates made to the
member database and it streams them to a
messaging system as a destination and
this in most cases at LinkedIn it's
Kafka and all of these various services
that need to know about changes made to
member profile data can just read from
the messaging system or Kafka in this
case and because Kafka has great read
scaling it can handle a bunch of
different services consuming the data
from Kafka at the same time and at
various points in time too so you can
have an application that's consuming
from the latest data which is the very
tail end of the topic or you can have
applications consuming from the earliest
start in time which is the the head of
the topic and Kafka can handle that
so the second major scenario that
Brooklyn is designed to handle is what
is known as a streaming bridge a
streaming bridge is applicable when you
want to move data between different
environments so for example you can use
Brooklyn to stream data between
different cloud services like AWS and
Azure you can also use Brooklyn to copy
data between different clusters and even
across data centers this is a
hypothetical example of Brooklyn being
used as a streaming bridge in this
example Brooklyn is consuming from two
Kinesis streams in AWS and writing the
data into two Kafka topics on link
within LinkedIn on premise that same
Brooklyn cluster is consuming from two
kafka topics two different Kafka topics
and writing the data into two event hubs
within answer so anytime you want to
stream data from X to Y is when a
streaming bridge is applicable having a
streaming bridge allows organizations to
enforce policies so for example you
might have a policy that states that any
data coming out of a particular source
must be encrypted because it has PII
data or you might have a policy that
states that any data
I mean with interview organization needs
to be of a particular format like JSON
or Avro and you can just configure your
data pipelines to enforce such policies
and it makes it easier for organizations
to manage if all of their data pipelines
are within one centralized service
instead of having many applications
running their own one-off pipelines but
perhaps the biggest streaming bridge
scenario at LinkedIn is to mirror kafka
data so Kafka is used extremely heavily
within LinkedIn and as most of you know
it even came out as a project coming out
of LinkedIn and we used it to store all
sorts of data like logging tracking and
metrics information so we use Brooklyn
to aggregate all of this Kafka data
between our from all of our data centers
to make it easy to access and process
from one centralized location Brooklyn
is also used heavily to move enormous
amounts of data between LinkedIn and
asier as most of you know LinkedIn was
acquired by Azure and now we have a huge
effort to move a lot of our data over to
Azure and perhaps the biggest scale test
for Brooklyn was the fact that it has
fully replaced Kafka mirror maker at
LinkedIn so for those of you who are not
familiar with Kafka mirror maker it is a
tool that is provided with open source
Kafka that simply supports copying data
from one Kafka cluster to another and
many companies use castamere maker for
this purpose but I LinkedIn we were
seeing a tremendous growth in the amount
of Kafka data year-over-year and Kafka
mere maker was just unable to scale up
with the amount of Kafka data that we
needed to handle it was difficult to
operate and manage and it had poor
failure isolation meaning that every
time there was an issue with mirroring a
particular Kafka topic or a particular
Kafka partition oftentimes the entire
kmm cluster would fall over and in fact
we were relying on a nanny job whose
sole purpose was to detect when kmm
clusters were down and simply restart
them so this just wasn't working well
for LinkedIn at LinkedIn scale and so
because we already built
a generic streaming service in Brooklyn
we decided to double down on Brooklyn
and use it to mirror all of this Kafka
data as well so when I talk about Kafka
mirroring pipelines with Brooklyn those
are simply cuff Brooklyn pipelines that
are configured with a Kafka source and a
Kafka destination and it was almost as
simple as that so by doing this we were
able to eliminate a lot of the
complexity around all of this kmm set up
at LinkedIn and this is best described
by showing you an example of what the
kmm topology used to look like at
LinkedIn taking this specific example
where we want to mirror two types of
data tracking and metrics data and we
want to aggregate that into their
respective aggregate tracking and
aggregate metrics clusters in each of
the three data centers to do this with
Kafka mirror maker we needed 18
different kmm clusters to do this
so imagine that if you wanted to make a
simple change because of the fact that
each cough c'mere maker cluster can only
support consuming from one kafka cluster
and writing to one Kafka cluster we
needed to support one cluster per
pipeline which is why we have 18 for
this news case here and so suppose that
if you wanted to make a simple change so
you wanted to add more topics to the
white list of let's say the metrics to
aggregate metrics pipelines we have to
do this in nine different places for
example the bottom nine kmm clusters
here because each one is controlled by a
static config we had to make this config
change manually nine different times and
then restart each kmm cluster for the
change to take effect but in reality we
have more than just metrics and tracking
information that we want to mirror in
LinkedIn and we have much more than just
three data centers so you can just
really imagine the number of Kafka
mirror maker clusters that we had to
manage it was actually in the hundreds
so this is the same example but using
Brooklyn instead to a mirror tracking
and metrics data into their respective
aggregate metrics and aggregate tracking
pipe clusters
in three data centers we only need three
Brooklyn clustered clusters to do this
because Brooklyn is multi-tenant it can
handle multiple data pipelines within
the same cluster and so if you wanted to
make a change the same change by adding
some topics to the metrics to aggregate
metrics pipeline you don't need to make
a config change in fact this can be done
dynamically and I'll show you this later
with when I dive into the Brooklyn
architecture so Brooklyn Kafka
Brooklyn's solution for Kafka Mearing
was really designed with operability and
stability in mind but we did need to
make some additional changes to Brooklyn
to support this use case despite the
fact that we already had the ability to
read and produce the Kafka originally
Brooklyn only supported reading from one
particular source like let's say one
database table or one Kafka topic and
writing in to one specific destination
like one Kafka topic but in order to
support the Kafka mirroring scenarios
and make it truly multi tenant we had to
support we had to add support in
Brooklyn to support a star to star or a
many-to-many configuration whereas when
one pipeline could consume from
thousands of topics and also mirror that
data into thousands of topics so in
order to do this we had to add a few
more features to make it truly to
provide true failure isolation because
we didn't want to repeat the same
mistakes that were that we sort of
introduced with our coffeemaker set up
where every time there was an issue with
mirroring one particular partition the
entire cluster would fall down so we
introduced the ability to manually pause
and resume these Brooklyn pipelines at
every granularity so for example you can
pause and resume the entire pipeline
just a specific topic within that
pipeline or even just a particular
partition within the stream we also
added the ability for Brooklyn to detect
whenever it is hitting some issue in
mirroring a particular partition or
topic and to auto pause those partitions
that are facing these possibly transient
issues
and Brooklyn can also automatically
resume after a configurable duration so
this really eliminated the need to
manually intervene whenever this
happened or we don't even rely on a
nanny job to do this anymore and the
important thing to notice is that
anytime a pipeline topic or partition is
paused
whether it be manually or automatically
the flow of messages from other
partitions remain unaffected so this is
truly multi-tenant and has good failure
isolation so now that I've covered the
change data capture and the streaming
bridge scenarios which Brooklyn was
intended for I'd like to talk about some
of the real use cases for Brooklyn
within LinkedIn one of the most common
use cases for change data capture
systems like Brooklyn is to keep a cache
up-to-date so for example when you want
when there's an update made to the real
database you want to make sure that that
change is also reflected in the cache
another example is search indices so
suppose that you change your profile to
reflect the fact that you now worked at
company X there can be a search
application that listens to these
changes and keeps some search indices
fresh so that you no longer show up in
the search results of your old company
but now you show up in the search
results of your new company X when you
have a source of truth databases
sometimes you want to do some offline
processing on this data and one way to
enable this is to ETL your data or push
this data into HDFS to do the offline
processing so you can ship these daily
snapshots from your database into HDFS
but if you do this your data could sort
of become out-of-date really fast
because you're only taking these
snapshots every at most every few hours
so what you can do instead is you can
consume from a Brooklyn change stream
and then more periodically merged these
live updates in with the last snapshot
that you've taken so that you can have a
fresher perspective on the data another
common use case is materialized views so
when you're modeling your
you're often choosing primary keys that
best fit the common access patterns of
your application but there might be
another application whose access
patterns differ from that so what you
can do is you can use Brooklyn to create
a materialized view where Brooklyn
consumes from once the the source of
truth and then it sort of repartition
the data based on a new primary key that
you took that you've chosen so this is
the same scenario repartition in here
where it doesn't have to be necessarily
materialized but Brooklyn can consume
from one stream and then we partition
that into another stream if you need a
different partition count or if you need
to partition by a different key so I'll
skip some up through the rest of these
application user spaces for the interest
of time but I think most of these I've
already covered now let's dive into the
architecture of Brooklyn to see how we
were able to achieve all of this to do
this I'm gonna take that same very
simple example where we want to stream
updates that are made to member profile
data namely this one here where Brooklyn
wants to capture live updates made to
member database and then write them into
Kafka where the newsfeed service can
consume from to power this use case here
to show job updates on the newsfeed for
all of Mochis connections so in this
case the source database is espresso
which is LinkedIn's document store and
the destination is Kafka and the
application consuming from it is called
the newsfeed service so the most the
it's really important to understand the
most fundamental concept of Brooklyn
which is a data stream a data stream is
basically a logical concept that
describes the data pipeline and it is a
mapping between the specific source and
the specific destination it also holds
the configuration of the pipeline for
example which application needs to
consume it and who are the owners of
this data stream so to kick this off to
kick off the provisioning of a data
pipeline a service needs to create a
data stream so in this case the
newsfeed service will go to our
self-service UI portal which we have in
LinkedIn it's a UI where application
developers can go to to select the
particular source that they are
interested in and the destination where
they would like their data to end up in
so someone will go and select espresso
member profile in the UI and select
Kafka as a destination and from there
when they click Save a create request
will go and it will hit one of our
Brooklyn instances specifically this
request will go to the data stream
management service which is a rest
endpoint that is exposed on all of our
Brooklyn instances and it can go to any
any of these Brooklyn instances so when
the Brooklyn instance the far left one
in this case receives that request it
simply writes it simply serializes the
data stream and writes it to zookeeper
so Brooklyn's only dependency is
zookeeper and we use this to store our
metadata namely our set of data streams
and we also use it for simple
coordination and leader election so once
this data stream is written into
zookeeper the leader coordinator which
is the one that was designated as the
leader at startup time by zoom standard
zookeeper election leader election
recipes the leader is notified that this
new data stream was written in zookeeper
and what it does is it calculates the
work distribution so it can break up the
data stream into what are known as data
stream tasks or the actual work units of
a data stream so for example if your
data is partitioned if your source data
is partitioned eight ways and it has
eight partitions for example the leader
coordinator could create eight different
data stream tasks so that each task
reads from a single partition so once it
just calculates the work distribution
the leader coordinator writes these
assignments back into zookeeper so it
writes it C realizes the data stream
tasks and writes them to zookeeper now
at this point in zookeeper each of the
Brooklyn instances has one or more tasks
and they get notified they're listening
to their own
Oh din zookeeper so they know when
something new has been assigned to them
and so the coordinator of each Brooklyn
instance is now notified of these new
tasks so these tasks sort of each hold a
copy of the original configuration of
the data stream so each of these tasks
specify that they need to read from the
member profile data and each task may
signal which partition that the Brooklyn
instance should consume from so how does
the coordinator know which consumer to
hand how does each coordinator within
the Brooklyn instance know which
consumer to hand off these tasks - well
the data stream definition had espresso
as a source so it knows that it needs to
hand off these tasks to the espresso
consumer and once these espresso
consumers receive the tasks they can
start to process the data from the
source so they can each start to consume
from their assigned partitions and start
reading the data so once they read start
streaming the data out of the data
source they propagate this data over to
the producers and the way that they know
which producers to hand off the data to
is within the data stream definition
again this time Kafka is the destination
so these consumers know that they need
to pass along their events over to the
Kafka producers once the Kafka producers
receive these events from the consumers
they can all right - Kafka and once the
data once the first date of the first
event hits Kafka the apps or in this
case the newsfeed service can start to
consume from Kafka asynchronously and as
I mentioned before Kafka provides good
rescaling so in the case that multiple
applications need to or they're
interested in consuming changes from
member profile data they can each follow
the steps that I mentioned before from
step one they can go to the self-service
UI portal and request that but Brooklyn
actually has some what is called as data
stream deduplication logic inside it so
that it knows that if there are many
like hundreds of application teams
wanting to consume from member profile
data it can reuse the same data stream
tasks and all of the same underlying
physical resources including the same
destination Kafka topic so it'll just
automatically point all of these new
applications over to the existing Kafka
topic that that was already created for
the newsfeed service use case and
Brooklyn also does some actual
management as well so it can ensure that
only the applications who have been
accepted to consume from this data
source can actually consume from the
Kafka destination so stepping away from
this specific example at a high level
this is what the Brooklyn architecture
looks like and this in this case you
only see three Brooklyn instances here
but at LinkedIn we managed Brooklyn
clusters that are like over six hundred
instances wide so here there are some
main components of Brooklyn zookeeper as
I mentioned before is used to store all
of the metadata as well as do some
coordination the data stream management
service is a rest endpoint that allows
users to dynamically act upon certain
data pipelines like create update read
delete pause partitions pause data
pipelines resume them and also to
retrieve like statistics about the
pipeline's we can also do that
dynamically each Brooklyn instance has
what is known as the coordinator which
is the brains of the system which is
responsible for the leader is
responsible for calculating and
distributing the tasks the coordinators
the other coordinators are responsible
for reading these data stream tasks and
then sort of distributing them to where
necessary
each Brooklyn instance can be configured
with any number of consumers as in if
you want to read from espresso Oracle
Kafka event hubs you would configure
your Brooklyn cluster to have four
different types of consumers in the same
respect Brooklyn can also be configured
with any number of different types of
producers so if you need to write to any
variety of destinations like event hubs
can
Kafka you can just configure your
Brooklyn cluster with those producers
and these consumer and producer
api's are standardized in a way that
it's very easy to extend these API is to
easily add support for new sources and
destinations which was one of the main
goals that we had when we started
Brooklyn so now that you have a an idea
of the architecture I'll talk about
where Brooklyn is today and what plans
we have going forward for it
currently Brooklyn supports a variety of
consumers we have espresso Oracle Kafka
event hubs and Kinesis and it also
supports two destinations namely Kafka
and event hubs some of the features of
Brooklyn are that first is that it's
multi tenant it can power thousands of
data streams across various sources and
destinations we do guarantee at least
once delivery meaning that we guarantee
that
each event is guaranteed at least once
to the destination and ordering of these
events are guaranteed and maintained at
a per partition level for the huge Kafka
mirroring use case to replace Kafka
mirror maker we had to add finer support
finer control of data pipelines like the
ability to pause and auto pause
partitions and we've also introduced
some features that improve the latency
such as something called fleshless
produce mode wherein we avoid calling
producer dot flesch which is a blocking
call on the Kafka producers and this has
helped improve our latency and what is
known as Kafka rebalances Brooklyn in
production today Brooklyn is in
production today and has been in
production since 2016 and Brooklyn
streams within brooklyn streams with
espresso or oracle as its source we
propagate third over 38 billion messages
a day over 2,000 data streams which is
over 1,000 unique sources because of
that data stream deduplication feature
that I mentioned earlier and we are
supporting over 200 applications within
LinkedIn for Brooklyn
supporting for Brooklyn clusters
mirroring Kafka data we are doing over
three trillion messages a day spanning
over 200 mirroring data pipelines and we
are mirroring tens of thousands of Kafka
topics and I'm happy to announce that
since June of this year
Brooklyn is now open source and is on
github but our work is not done we still
want to add more support for new sources
and destinations namely on the source
side we want to support my sequel cosmos
DB and Azure sequel to name a few and on
the destination side we want to write to
Azure blob storage Kinesis cosmos DB a
sure sequel and Couchbase and the
interesting thing about these
destinations is that some of these are
storage where in previously our
destinations were event hubs and Kafka
so there are more streaming messaging
systems so we'll introduce some new
features in Brooklyn to allow for
batching to support these storage
destinations and we want to optimize
Brooklyn even further we want to add
ability for Brooklyn to auto scale
automatically based on the throughput
needs of the data pipelines in
near-real-time we also want to roll out
this feature called pass-through
compression so which will help the
throughput by at least five X for our
Kafka mirroring scenarios so when you
mirror Kafka data from one cluster to
another it's very simple it's just a we
just want to have a big fat pipe that
mirrors bytes of data from one place to
another but the problem is that the
Kafka consumer which is the you know the
Kafka client in open source Kafka the
coffeehouse consumer what it does is it
automatically DC realises all of the
events that are read and in a tree and
then the Kafka producer Ricci realises
that data when producing to the
destination
so this serialization deserialization
serialization takes up actually over 70%
of our CPU and we don't care about the
message the event boundaries in this
case because we are simply mirroring
we're not doing any data processing
we're not looking into the payload of
these Kafka events so we want to do
what's called pass-through
we're and we disable the deserialization
and the resale is a ssin of these
messages and we simply write bites bites
out and bites in so this would we've
shown that this can give us a 5x
throughput increase another thing that
we want to do is we want to make some
read optimizations where we want to be
able to read once and write to multiple
destinations so in the case that I
mentioned earlier where all of these
application teams are consuming from the
same Kafka destination because they're
all interested in member profile data
there may be some cases where they don't
want to share the same underlying topic
and in this case we want to be able to
read from espresso once and then write
to maybe 10 different Kafka topics but
the challenge with that is that as I
mentioned each application can be at
their own pace so we need to be able to
handle that too lastly I just want to
thank all of you again for choosing to
attend my presentation I think I have
three minutes for any questions but if
you have any questions outside please
feel free to find me or message me on
any of these channels you can message me
on LinkedIn you can send me a direct
email to my LinkedIn email address or
you can ask questions on our github or
sorry on our Gator channel we're really
active on getter and you can check out
our source code on github thank you
[Applause]
yeah so the question is can we can
people easily write their own consumers
and producers too that are maybe outside
of the scope of what we have in the
future and yes the answer is yes we're
open source now so anyone is free to
contribute the api's are pretty standard
so it's I'm sorry what language ok so
right now we support Java yeah Brooklyn
is written completely in Java yep yeah
so the question is that Brooklyn seems
to have a lot of overlap with Kafka
Connect and the museum some of the
features that I think are a little bit
unique about Brooklyn is that so let's
say Kafka Connect for example I think
with Kafka Connect you can configure a
connector with it but if you configure a
source or yeah if you couldn't figure a
source then the sync is automatically
Kafka and if you configure a sync then
the source is automatically Kafka so you
can do either source or destination as
Kafka and then sort the other one can be
something else
whereas Brooklyn can stream anything
from X to Y so we don't even need to
involve Kafka there the museum is from
my understanding it is known more for
change data capture which is you can
easily write plugins to consume from a
variety of databases but Brooklyn can
also read from messaging systems it can
do batching so that it can write back
into data stores and it can do Kafka -
Kafka event hubs - Kinesis I think it's
if I were to summarize I think it's a
little bit more customizable yeah
yeah so yeah what is the question around
yeah so for example so the question is
can I give some examples of policies and
how they are enforced so for example if
you have a particular data set that is
private you can say that this needs to
be encrypted and therefore you can
there's a way for you to in to configure
your data pipelines to let Brooklyn know
that this is an encrypted data stream
and that it may need to read the keys
for that source from a particular key
management service and then also when it
ships the events it needs to also use
that same key to encrypt those messages
and the applications also needs to use
their that key to decrypt it on the
other end and so at LinkedIn we have
services like a key management service
which enables us to do this so it's all
within the configuration of a data
pipeline yep
okay so the question is is there any
initiative to push Brooklyn over to
Apache Apache is something that we did
evaluate but going forward as a company
LinkedIn is is is moving away from
Apache yeah okay thank you please feel
free to reach out to me if you have any
questions thank you
[Applause]